hi everyone i am anketh
i completed my masters in scientific
computing and
i worked in industry in various roles as
a data scientist
product manager and a software developer
throughout this journey my core focus
has always been to help people
accelerate their data analytics and
scientific computing pipeline
and today i'll be talking about number
which is one such
tool which can help you supercharge your
scientific computing code in python
to begin with we researchers love python
because it is easy to learn the codes
written
are usable and readable it has a vast
ecosystem of more than 250 000 plus
contributed packages it takes fewer
lines of code
to implement new algorithms and build
prototypes
and scale them a feature rich jupiter
notebook
ecosystem allows us to have an
interactive environment
where we can write our codes
mathematical equations
display visualizations and add narrative
text
this even promotes reproducible research
and scientific transparency
and the list goes on and on
but when i was pursuing my masters six
years back
working on transport phenomena solving
multiple differential equations
i was hit very hard by the fact that
when it comes to performance
python implementation was magnitudes
slower when compared to traditional
languages
like fortran and c plus which made me
question if learning python is so easy
why is increasing the performance of my
python code
so difficult
thankfully times have changed a lot of
effort
has been made in the last decade and two
to accelerate python
you can have a look at some of the
alternative implementations
and packages which aid acceleration in
this need for speed timeline
broadly there are two ways to speed up
your python codes
one is by using a replacement python
interpreter
like pipey which is difficult to
implement which has its own ecosystem of
python packages
which is significantly smaller and
limited
the other popular alternative is to use
python to see
c plus plus transpilers like nuetca
python and cyton they have limited
static analysis
and ahead of time generated code is
either bloated
or underspecialized also both these
alternatives do not address non-cpu
targets like gpus
which are gaining widespread adoption in
the scientific computing community
and then there is one library number
which stands out in this crowd
it is easy to learn use and implement
just like learning python and it often
provides performance gains
comparable to traditional programming
languages
as there is no ahead of time compilation
step
so using it is straightforward and you
can directly plug it in
into your jupyter notebook environment
so what is number it is an open source
jit compiler
which translates a subset of python and
numpy code into fast machine code
all you need to do is add a jit
decorator
to your python function and you will
gain performance similar to cc
plus and fortran without switching
languages
or interpreters to understand how number
works
we can quickly go through the process
which happens
behind the scene so first you add the ng
decorator
to the function you want to accelerate
engine stands for
jit in no python mode which is the
preferred mode
to supercharge your code as there is
zero involvement
of the python interpreter in the
compiled code and this leads to the best
performance
when the function is invoked for the
first time in the session
a byte code analysis of the python
function is performed based on which
a number intermediate representation is
generated
the function arguments are also analyzed
to infer the data types
post which the ir is rewritten this
high level and abstract number ir
goes through the process of lowering
which
converts it into low level and machine
specific
ln vmir based on the cpu
or gpu target the llvm or nvvm
compiler infrastructure is used to
generate
optimized machine code which is executed
if you pass cache equal to true option
then it will persist the compiled code
on your disk which can be used
across sessions
so let's get started with our first
example we will compute the mandelbrot
set
a set of points on the complex plane
which always remains bounded
by a threshold value while solving the
quadratic recurrence equation
it is an iterative problem which is also
very compute intensive in nature
the first step is to import the
requisite libraries
which we will be using throughout this
exercise
next we will set up the domain size as
a 500 cross 500 grid and limit
the maximum iteration for each point on
the grid
to 1000
now let us write a pure python function
to evaluate the mandelbrot set
and return a nested list of color tuples
for the entire domain since we are using
only python
we will use the data structures
available natively
we will initialize a nested list of
tuples
denoting the color of each pixel on the
complex plane
next we will traverse the complex plane
using nested for loops
here y denotes the index along the
imaginary axis
and x denotes the index along the real
axis
the complex number corresponding to each
grid point is initialized
and we begin the iterative computation
when c breaches the threshold value
after a certain
number of iterations the corresponding
color tuple is evaluated using a
mathematical function
finally the function returns the color
of the entire grid
let us now execute the function
you can see it took around seven seconds
to execute the entire function
we can visualize the generated
mandelbrot set using the python image
link library
it looks fascinating now let us see if
we can
speed up the entire computation using
number
all we need to do is create a copy of
the above function
and add the num budget decorator
let us execute the function wow
it took less than a second now let us
execute it again
the performance improved even further
since we did not provide any
specification regarding the function
input types in the ng decorator number
does a lazy
compilation of the function when the
function is executed for the first time
it does the type inferencing and
compiles the code which is directly used
for all successive execution
we test the results and yeah it looks
good
so we got an enormous performance boost
just by applying the engine decorator
but is that
it no number also provides you with
certain options
that can enhance the performance even
further
all you need to do is switch the
parallel option to true
and number will generate codes capable
of
parallel execution on multiple threads
in this case we will also specify the
for loop
we want to execute in parallel using the
p range function available in number
so i have parallelized the loop
execution along the y
axis so let us now execute the function
amazing it took less than 100
milliseconds this time
you can clearly see the improvement in
performance
is even further so you can inspect the
default number of threads
that are being used by number using the
number num threads
config variable in my case it is 16
and you can also set the number of
threads which can be used
by number using the set num threads
function
let us set the number of threads as 4
and execute it
some other options available in the nj
decorator are fast math
and cache fast matter reduces the
numerical rigor
which can help you gain further
improvement in performance
also you can persist the compiled code
on disk
which can help you avoid the overhead
you experience
in the first run
now let us move to the next example
where we will use
numpy array as the data structure you
can see the code logic
is exactly the same as we had in the
pure python version
if you are new to numpy you are and you
are not familiar with vectorization
and array expressions you will tend to
use for loops to access
and modify arrays in this function i am
doing the same
now let me execute the function
you can witness the function is not up
to the mark as
accessing numpy arrays using for loops
is quite expensive
let us see if number comes to our rescue
we once again create a copy of the
function and add the ng decorator
after executing the function we can see
that the performance gain is quite
significant and
slightly better than what we achieved
using the
pure python code now
let us switch the parallel option to
true and add the period function
and execute it
this time the performance gain is quite
significant
because though numpy is primarily
designed
to be high performant on single core
number
automatically compiles a version which
can run
in parallel if it contains reduction
functions
array math functions and many more
functions
assignments and operations
you are well versed in numpy universal
functions and vectorization
number can still help you speed up your
scientific computing pipeline
as it allows you to write u funcs in
python
instead of c and directly compiling into
numpy ufunk there is a numpy counterpart
vectorized decorator
which vectorizes a python function
but it is just for simplicity and it is
neither optimized
nor efficient
so let us first start with the numpy
vectorize decorated function
you can witness its performance is
slightly better than the nested for
loops
once we switch to the number vectorized
decorator we are able to compile it into
a u-func
which performs significantly better
to add icing to the cake you can also
create a u-func which can execute
in parallel using the target option
which increases the performance even
further
as we can see here
moving to the final example we will
solve the diffusion equation where a
steel square block
is at an initial temperature of 300
kelvin and
it is subjected to 700 kelvin boundary
temperature
we will solve the differential equations
using central difference method
in space and forward difference method
in time
we will set up the domain provide the
initial conditions and define the
thermal properties
the number of time steps we will
undertake is 500
and the you not specifies the
temperature field at time t equal to
zero
using for loops we have a readable code
now
let us go ahead and execute the function
it takes around 12 seconds to execute we
can plot the temperature field and
inspect it
now let us rewrite the function using
numpy vectorized expression
this totally eliminates the need for for
loops
after executing the code we are able to
obtain 200 times faster performance
but the sacrifice is huge in terms of
code readability
the more complex the equation the more
difficulty we will have
in understanding the code
number provides a stencil decorator
which comes to a rescue
a stencil is a computational pattern
which
automatically generates the looping code
required for a neighborhood
it allows clearer more concise and high
performance code
we start by defining a kernel which
computes the equation we want to
apply on the domain and add the stencil
decorator
in case the kernel is not applicable on
the boundaries
the output value of the boundaries are
defaults to zero
this can be changed via c val parameter
as we have specified in this case which
is t
hot or 700 kelvin now
let us go ahead and execute the code
the performance gain is more than 700
times
which clearly demonstrates how you can
supercharge your scientific computing
code
using number without hampering the code
readability
to summarize it is a good idea to use
number
for numerical algorithms which are arrow
oriented
math heavy have lot of loops
when the data is in the form of numpy
arrays
when the performance bottlenet is a
handful of well
encapsulated functions you can use
number
to create universal functions in python
that can be broadcasted over numpy
arrays instead of writing them using c
apis
you can also use number to generate
parallel codes targeting multi-core cpus
and gpus and as we have already seen you
can create
fast and clean codes using the stencil
kernels
now let us check out a real life open
source project which has benefited from
number acceleration
the name of the project is blur hash
number which is the fastest python 3
blurage implementation
you can go ahead and check out the
project source
and the interactive demo on github.com
animator slash blurage number it is also
available as a python package
on piping
so blurrage is actually quite popular
and used in popular sites such as reddit
medium as a placeholder while the
network image is still loading
so bloodrush algorithm takes an image
and gives a short string which is only
20 to 30 characters that represents the
placeholder for this image
so the process of encoding is basically
conversion of an image
into a blura string and the process of
decoding
is the conversion of this blur hash
string into a blurred
image
i will now share some performance
testing results for both
the encoding and decoding
implementations and compare it to the
pure python blur rash implementation
as compared to pure python
implementation
in blurage number there was a speed up
of
around 33 to 63 times while encoding an
image
with sizes ranging from 128 across 128
pixels to 204 it crossed two zero four
red pixels
also the process of decoding saw a
performance boost of 34 to 70 times
for the same target image sizes
such performance gains can have a
tremendous financial impact and help you
save money
when you are running image processing
algorithms like blur hash
on serverless frameworks where you are
built based on the function usage
which mostly includes the runtime
in case you are already using dusk or
rapids
number integrates with them seamlessly
also you can install number using berry
countdown raspberry pi
and speed up edge device computation for
example machine learning scoring
or any other s device analytical
computation
i have personally tried it and it works
really well
the manual broad set example that we
executed today
was also executed on raspberry pi and
the performance gain was
more than 20 times with this we have
come to an end to this talk
if you have any questions please feel
free to ask me in the q a session
you can find the notebooks used in this
talk on my website which is real
worldpython.guide
so thank you for attending this talk and
have a nice day
you